.
>> Laura: AND THAT'S "THE
ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW IS
STEPHEN MILLER, FORMER ADVISOR
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND ALSO BEN
DOMENECH, EDITOR AT LARGE OF THE
SPECTATOR AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
STEPHEN, DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
WERE TRYING TO HOBBLE HER EARLY
ON WHEN THEY GET FOR THE BORDER
ASSIGNMENT?
>> I THINK THEY KNEW EARLY ON,
WE'VE ALL FIGURED OUT, WHICH IS
THAT SHE IS HORRENDOUSLY
INCOMPETENT, TOTALLY USELESS,
HAS THE SPEAKING SKILLS AT BEST
OF A FIRST GRADER FOR BEING
GENEROUS AND HAS ABSOLUTELY NO
ABILITY TO DO ANYTHING USEFUL
WHATSOEVER.
AND SINCE THEY KNEW -- IT'S VERY
SICK, BUT THEY KNEW THE BORDER
WAS GOING TO BE IN A
NEVER-ENDING STATE OF CRISIS,
THEY FIGURE THEY MIGHT AS WELL
LAID OUT ON HER, EVEN THOUGH OF
COURSE WE KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
AND THIS WILL THE